you said that this album is your most
honest album so why do you think so
because I started so young there's a
huge part of me that didn't get a chance
to develop my identity in a normal
setting so when I was working with
Disney it was the best time of my life
and I had a great time I have nothing
but good things to say but it was a bit
more controlled there were certain
things that I was you know kind of not
had to do and not maybe go into like
figuring out what my sound would be so I
I've constantly been trying to make my
music better and better because you know
I I know that people may not think I'm
the greatest singer but I just worked my
ass off and I love I really loved
writing and creating and creating
melodies and growing and I felt like
this was my chance to say all the things
that I wanted to say and in that way
which was talking about relationships
and talking about difficult times or
being vulnerable or or being stuck in
your head because you know I can do that
a lot and but I wanted it to feel good
you know I wanted it to feel like every
word mattered and you could feel it
physically and I'm still in the studio
actually now because I've I feel like
it's inspired me and I just want to keep
going ahead of time yeah in that funny
you making out that always happens with
me too I make an album and then I'm all
and then after I'm releasing like right
while I'm doing and I'm doing another
way exactly it always happens something
like I don't know but I want to point
something out because doing the voice
especially it has been really
interesting because a lot of people
always think cuz you said oh I know
people might not say the best singer the
best singer in the world talking to
everyone in the world right now it's not
the loudest and it's not the you know oh
my god you've just sing like Whitney
Houston every time you get the best
singers in the world move you and and
that comes from all different sounds and
styles so like from a singer to a singer
it's beautiful what you do and I love
your record and I I love big huge songs
but I love singing your music it means
something and it moves people so don't
ever negate your gift because it's
powerful
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my Channel please don't
make me keep going